[Musique]
bien bonjour à tous pour ce nouveau pas
cette version profite et on va tenter
d'y voir un petit peu plus clair dans la
lutte finalement entre ces deux
objectifs qui peuvent apparaître
autre victoire c'est à dire d'un côté de
préserver la santé des français les
préserver du virus et puis de l'autre
bah comment relancer l'économie puisque
vous le savez on a passé la barre des 10
millions de chômeurs l'endettement de
l'unedic a à peu près 60 milliards il ya
un effondrement de la demande il ya une
difficulté des difficultés croissantes
pour les entreprises
et puis à cette date du 11 mai qui a été
indiqué par le président de la
république bat sur laquelle il semble
être un petit peu au froid venu hier
petite ever veillant à des confirmands
différents selon les régions
alors pour parler de tous ces problèmes
florence mercadé ce qu'est bonjour
bonjour patrice vous êtes avocate au
barreau de versailles
anne failli bonjour vous êtes directeur
du développement économique de saint
quentin sa carrière dit bonjour aussi
vous êtes président du medef yvelines
syrie dit bonjour vous allez voir au
docteur vous êtes journaliste vous
présenter le le grand journal des
territoires sur tv5 monde pour vitré
athénée 78 d'ailleurs et on est ravi de
vous accueillir
merci s'est pas présenté encore michael
l'aube roseaux bonjour bonjour bonjour
tout le monde
leurs sept chirurgiens dentistes à
versailles et il me manque et jean
charles lajoie ni bonjour à tous vous ça
va mais bien bien bien bien en attente
la rue des maras du pays et dès
l'ouverture des librairies à me libérer
puisque vous êtes éditeur dont le rappel
et de mission et est réalisée par romain
respini alors bon le diagnostic j'en ai
un petit peu parlé mais c'est vrai que
les prévisions sur la croissance ou sont
plutôt à des croissances sur les
déficits sont absolument terribles
le projet de 6 à 10 % au second
trimestre il faut s'attendre à un recul
du pib de 2 15%
donc des chiffres terribles je voudrais
savoir justement sa carrière 10 ou par
exemple vous avez dit cité vous avez une
entreprise président du bébête mais vous
avez aussi une autre crise évidemment
vous avez décidé de resté ouvert malgré
le confinement comment ça se passe
bonjour patrice bonjour à tous
effectivement je suis chef d'entreprise
donc pour être président du mataf
louette entrepreneurs soi même est en
réalité dès le 15 mars j'ai décidé
effectivement de rester ouverts parce
qu'on a eu de décret dans la nuit qui ne
permettait d'être ouvert et d'être
autorisés à ouvrir alors c'est très
simple nous avons discuté avec les
collaborateurs et nous avons organisé à
mardan le cadre du confinement que nous
reconnaît la réalité ou également j'ai
tiré un peu la réalité des choses et
nous avons divisé les cités par deux ça
c'est le premier point pour respecter la
distanciation
nous avons équipé les équipes de masques
et de gants et nous avons pas les
horaires d'ouverture du lundi au samedi
au lieu du lundi au dimanche et nous
avons contre les horaires journaliers de
m'avoir à bobigny et de 14 à 18 pour un
peu genou et dignité
nos contacts avec la clientèle et les
clients l'ont adapté très vite nous
avons communiqué dessus et nous avons
également permis à nos unions de pouvoir
prendre part au rendez-vous et de se
présenter au magasin pour éviter une
influence sur des horaires un peu reste
là voilà ce qu'on a fait
plus comment vous pouvez quand même
travaillé pendant la période du
confinement en prenant les précautions
lui d'hôtes
absolument et on ne travaillait en
respectant les justes barrières et plus
appel c'est très important il faut la
vidéo qu'en dites-vous shepparton passé
aujourd'hui je vous présente c'est pas
beau il vous êtes vous êtes ancien
président industrie par notre ex
excusez moi évidemment votre expertise
est intéressante puisque vous connaissez
très bien la vie des entreprises
en fait justement comment ça se passe
pour les entreprises où j'occupais à
saint quentin sur 50 ans en exil
on a finalement l'ensemble des
situations qu'on retrouve au niveau
national parce que c'est une économie
qui à la fois résidentiel
c'est aussi un tissu d'ingénérie est
plus un tissus technologiques et
productif et finalement les situations
sont en train de plus commun c'est un
impact évidemment très fort sur
l'activité de nos entreprises
nous sommes en relation avec elles avec
j'avais aujourd'hui 400 500 contacts qui
ont été réalisées globalement elle juge
que l'impact des efforts l identique
entre cinq et dix comme étant très donc
avec un impact impact important avec des
situations qui sont des documents à la
pâte et toute l'équipe en lien avec les
330 commerçants qui sont aujourd'hui
ouverts sur saint quentin en yvelines
puisque ont participé à la remise des
masques apportée par par la région ça
nous a permis de faire le point avec
avec tous les commerçants on voit bien
des situations effectivement très très
très différente des chiffres d'affaires
de perte de chiffre d'affaires qui sont
y compris pour les commerces ouverts
entre entre 15 et 25%
certains d'entre eux par contre ont une
activité montré très dense notamment sur
l'alimentation générale de proximité
mais une économie résidentielle saint
quentin en yvelines qui est bien sûr un
pacte
et pour mémoire nous avons 2500 commerce
sur 50 ans nîmes il est donc je vous le
disais hier à 330 qui sont aujourd'hui
ouverts sur la partie plutôt activités
stratégiques
clairement nous avons des activités que
l'on était poursuivi par une rencontre
je pense notamment aux sites de atos ou
de ou de safran qui sont là pour
permettre des communications sécurisées
pour les grands opérateurs français donc
il ya des activités qui ont pu être
maintenus depuis depuis le 16 16 mars
gros point de vigilance sur toute
l'algérie vous avez que c'est une
composante importante de notre tissu
économique
aujourd'hui la question des études
confiées par par les grands comptes est
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt est ce que vous
n'avez plus de question à la fois sur
l'activité de ses grands comptes d'un
doublé comme de nos petits bureaux
d'études
ce qui pose cette question quant au
développement de produits nouveaux à
horizon à horizon un an donc un tissu
économique qui évidemment malgré toutes
ses qualités fortement impactés nous
sommes aux côtés des choses entre
l'entreprise pour les guider dans les
différentes mesures nationales que
régionales moment les deux mesures entre
maintenant et sur la question du mise en
place du retour progressif des équipes
j'ai justement cyril viguier puisque
vous présenter le grand journal des
territoires est ce qu est ce que vous
constatez des est-ce que vous constaté
des différences justement entre les
territoires est est ce que on a la
pression quand même qu'il ya des régions
qui sont moins affectés par le virus
est ce que vous constatez c'est cette
différence qu absolument patrice bonjour
à tous les moins bien sûr il y à des
régions j'allais dire qui échappe
totalement au cauchemar que vivent
d'autres régions c'est valable aussi
dans nos métiers vous savez beaucoup de
médias dans certaines régions fonctionne
extrêmement bien regarder c'est le cas
d'abord de vous de vous même de télé 78
d'autres vous n'avez même pas de
stations régionales de france 3 qui
fonctionne donc à une disparité énorme
en réalité de ce qu'ils peuvent traiter
cette crise ou pas c'est une évidence et
je pense que quand on a écouté les
propos du premier ministre et du
président de la république ces dernières
heures ils ont saisi compris que le
déconfinement se ferait par étape
probablement en fonction de ce type de
considération quelles régions fonctionne
quelle région ne fonctionne pas et
comment au fond éviter les disparités
tout en remettant un petit à petit le
pays entier au travail et on aura
vraiment parce que probablement cette
crise du virus cette cascade du jeu il
faut l'appeler va peut-être changer nos
points de vue justement sur la
décentralisation sur le fait qu tête il
vaut mieux prendre des mesures là où les
gens sont concernés ils foucher en tant
qu'expert comptable quels sont les
retours que vous avez vous des
entreprises bonjour à tous ce sont les
mêmes que celles évoquées par un failli
hakkari tout ce qui est je dirais
services intellectuels continue à
travailler plus ou moins étant vient pas
c'est le cas de mon cabinet où on à 220
personnes en en télétravail mais enfin
cesser à la fin des fins et pas une
solution faut quand même pas se cacher
derrière son petit doigt parce qu'on
produit la moitié de ce qu'on produit
habituellement
et puis on voit les limites du numérique
de nuit qui s'émerveille et on peut plus
s'en passer
sauf que c'est pas la brède il vous faut
arrêter de se le dire donc ça c'est un
premier problème est le drame absolu
c'est tous les commerces qui sont admis
et les activités qui sont
administrativement fermées depuis depuis
le le 17 parties moi je suis je suis
bouleversée je veux dire on nous parle
matin midi et soir et je compatis et je
suis en pleine promo passion pour les
gens qui le subissent des morts dus
qu'aux vide mais il faut arrêter les
bords économique du coc bible vont être
charles 10 50 - nombreux faux faux il me
faut qu'on arrête moi je regarde
attentivement le modèle suédois parce
que
c'est intéressant jean charles lajoie
dit peut-être en tant que j'ai dit vous
êtes éditeur vous avez su comment
comment ça se passe qu il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de débris sont fermés d il
ya des livres qui sont pas nombreux
nouveaux comme encore au billard des
livres qui se vendent d'abord il ya un
rebond dû à un décollage presque du
livre numérique
oui donc ça c'est assez intéressant
alors le livre numérique ça représente
quand même que entre 5 et 8% du marché
de l'édition en france de logo pas
beaucoup donc là c'est en train de
quasiment deux doublés donc ça va
peut-être arriver à 10% ce qui n'est
quand même pas négligeable
donc ça très intéressant après il ya
aussi des nobles
c'est très mauvais de le dire en public
etc
mais amazon avant que les syndicats
arrivent à le faire fermer pendant cinq
jours livrer les livres qu'ils avaient
en stock et c'était quand même quelque
chose de très bien
laflaque le faisait aussi de grandes
librairies dès le début ont dès le début
fait des des drive ou des livraisons les
livraisons sont tout à fait autorité
on peut livrer des sandwichs on peut
également livré des livres donc il n'ya
pas de problème après nous on travaille
et on est très très inquiet et très
perplexe sur la le redémarrage parce que
ni samples acquis que les librairies
rouvriront le 11è le 11 mai mais dans
quel état
un bruit court que le le client n'aurait
pas le droit de toucher les livres
alors si on ne rentre dans une finale et
qu'on n'a pas le droit de prendre le
livre en main de regarder la quatrième
de couverture
à quoi ça sert d'aller dans une
librairie à temps là on reste chez soi
et commande sur internet et puis la
messe est dite
donc ce que nous faisons sur ridicule
sion doit pour y arriver comme allemand
ben oui non mais voilà c'est tout tu dis
il ya parfois des mesures qui sont qui
sont pires que le mal et il faut faire
attention à ça je suis d'accord et que
il fouchères fois faisons attention vers
restons quand même sur l'idée que ceux
se coronavirus c'est dans 99% des cas
une maladie non létales donc arrêtons
aussi et que
avoir des cordes de gens qui vont être
au bord du suffit parce
qu'économiquement
ils seront à genoux ils ne pourront plus
nourrir leur famille face à va être ça
va être d'aider probablement déçus si d
une véritable catastrophe
alors c'est bien on a sauvé le service
de réanimation n'a sauvé des tas de
choses mais maintenant peut-être pensons
aussi à à ne pas sur réagir et ne pas se
laisser dicter une loi que le politique
reprenne un peu son son rôle est pas et
pas seulement la médecine j'ai voté
blanc de la république j'ai pas voté
pour un médecin
donc j'aimerais que ce soit les
politiques qui décident d'un talent rare
et je pense que la date du 11 mai qui a
été annoncé par emmanuel macron c'était
une façon de forcer un peu les nail
réticences des administrations être des
médecins d'ailleurs puisqu'on en est aux
diagnostics en oeuvre rapidement mais
florence mercadé choqué et mikel
lumbroso vous êtes des professions
libérales alors il ya la justice qui est
qui alors pour le coup pratiquement
arrêté vous êtes aux chirurgiens
dentistes aussi on sait que les
professions de santé enfin les gens ne
vont plus voir les autres médecins que
ceux qui traitent du coville peut-être
sur la sur la sur la justice d'abord
florence woerth avait choqué est sûre et
sur la situation de des avocats oui
alors effectivement nous on subit de
plein fouet deux à deux causes
premièrement effectivement la fermeture
des tribunaux pour savoir que de très
nombreux et beaucoup de la majorité des
avocats big des contentieux judiciaires
et ont suivi derrière aussi les
entreprises qui par les a complétés au
début la mise en place de l'activité
partielle et depuis ils n'ont pas très
envie d'engager des frais pour et un
avocat
alors il ya une enquête qui a été fait
par la conférence nationale etc a sorti
des chiffres qui sont assez par sortir
de là avec une très grande précarité
la 39% des avocats ce délire bas niveau
4 est rayé du tableau de l'ordre parce
que ils devront pas payer les
cotisations il manque un cabinet
d'avocats 28%
les avocats vont changer de métier
si pensant vont partir en retraite
anticipée 5 % vont fermer leurs cabinets
41% ont déjà cessé leur activité
62 demandé l'aide de l'état pour toucher
les 1500 euros de one man donc posté
c'est une vraie catastrophe et on
s'attend à des liquidations judiciaires
de cabinets d'avocats et des
catastrophes pourquoi les cabinets donc
on attend
michael mégalo bronzo pour les
professions de santé
pour nous les dentistes nous sommes à
l'arrêt complet depuis le 16 mars
on assure une forme d'urgence
téléphonique ou par mail et là j'ai même
mis en place des visioconférences
parfois avec des avec des patients pour
essayer de les soulager et de par des
ordonnances des choses comme ça mais
évidemment c'est pas du tout une
solution est évidemment nous avons
n'avons plus aucun revenu en tant que co
professions libérales
évidemment il ya un problème économique
mais surtout nous ce qui nous inquiète
c'est les conditions de la reprise il ya
énormément de flou encore énormément
d'interrogations
nous n'avons pas de masque par exemple
et cpe
le gouvernement a débloqué 150 mille
bastia pour notre profession
cent cinquante mille masques ça
représente un jour c'est donc là nous
avons énormément de questions auxquelles
ni le gouvernement ni nos instances ne
savent répondre pour l'instant
et voilà on est vraiment dans
l'expectative et c'est pas du tout du
tout comment la reprise va pouvoir se
faire et dans quelles conditions
si bédié se réjouir vraiment parce que
ce mot si on regarde ce tableau il est
quand même assez terrible à ses droits
c'est sombre que ce soit pour les
entreprises que ce soit pour les
professions libérales
c'est une économique est totalement à
l'arrêt vous qui avez justement que
cette vision globale avec le territoire
entier est-ce que vous avez aussi ce
diagnostic vous revient ce diagnostic un
peu un peu noir un peu sombre de la
situation et la difficulté peut-être
d'en sortir
l'incertitude de savoir comment faire
pour régler cette situation
oui la certitude c'est ce qui pèse sur
l'ensemble de fin des secteurs de
l'économie
en revanche je on peut pas non plus a
totalement pessimiste sur la manière
dont un moment donné les gens vous
vouloir réagir la consommation repartir
il ya aussi une prise de conscience à
cause de cette crise que nous étions
quand même malgré ce qu'ont raconté
depuis des années dans une envie de
consommer dans une frénésie peut-être
même pour la demande trop par rapport à
et que nous menions mais moi je reste
plein d'espoir quant à la le désirent à
volonté forte les énergies qui aura
partout de vouloir recommencer repartir
peut-être plus encore ce rabais quand
même on est tous d'anaheim on peut se
rappeler quels étaient les années 60 les
années 70 les années 50 même les années
d'après guerre
finalement on est quand même reparti et
où le plaisir
moi je réfléchis en regardant les rues
dans paris depuis ce confinement regarde
je réfléchis aux jeunes qui ont vu
arriver les chars allemands et tous
éteindre un moment donné dans paris et
qui se disait à l'époque que tout était
fini
et bien tout n'a pas été fini c'est
reparti un jour on est on est on est un
peu dans ce dans ce type de
problématique c'est qu'on a on n'a
aucune visibilité sur l'avenir mais
qu'on pressent ressent au fond que ça ça
peut repartir il ya une autre chose sur
lequel je voudrais intervenir tout à
l'heure puisque ne vous invité patrice a
parlé des professions médicales
il ya des choses sur lequel il faudra
revenir j'étais extrêmement frappé mois
sur tous les plateaux de télévision de
voir comment dirais je ne la gênait pas
que c'était le cas je sais que c'était
le cas dans nos métiers l'audiovisuel
ou c'est le cas dans la politique une
telle antagonismes de telle haine
personnelle même entre les grands
représentants des professions médicales
et grands médecins les grands
professeurs entre ils ont cette crise a
beaucoup choqué de ce point de vue là à
laisser éclater au fond que dans cette
profession dans ces métiers pourtant
dont on attend beaucoup de déontologie
beaucoup de beaucoup d' expertise ils
ont laissé éclater une forme
d'antagonisme de haine entre eux qui m'a
qui m'a beaucoup frappée je pense que ce
que ça restera un et le personnel
soignant a été extraordinaire toutes les
campagnes pour les secourir ont été
fabuleuses
il ya eu un engouement extraordinaire
une redécouverte de ces professions et
de ses sincères dos pour la plupart de
la part du grand public et des gens mais
mes 7 mondiaux cette haine palpable qui
a été visible aux yeux de tous
entre ses professeurs de médecine qui
n'étaient pas d'accord les uns avec les
autres m'a énormément frappé et je pense
que là dessus patrice on reviendra aussi
sur beaucoup de beaucoup de
considération établis avant cette crise
aussi ce sentiment là parfois les
chaînes d'info évidemment exacerbée tout
ça ça n'a pas été le cas d'ailleurs des
chaînes locales qui ont fait des
reportages évidemment beaucoup plus
intéressant moi j'allais dire sur le
monde ou d'arrêter oui bien sûr et moi
mais on reviendra sur tous à ses pieds
et à sochaux pour analyser tout ça mais
je pense que des des mentalités
nouvelles émergent dont 2,7 de cette
crise du côté de 19
je vous propose d'en reparler dans un
prochain numéro est obligé de vous
libérer parce que je crois que vous avez
une une obligation qui profite merci
beaucoup ziri lescar vous sa carrière
dit justement alors cette date du 11 mai
est-ce que vous
vous êtes pression du milieu humide
affective je le rappelle est ce que les
entreprises des chefs d'entreprise vous
appelle vous disais mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer comme on va refaire qu
est-ce qu on est démasqué ce qu'il faut
qu'on déteste
est-ce que sk une inquiétude et une
incertitude sur cette reprise du 11 mai
sur cette date du 11 mai disons que il
ya une réflexion qui dit donc pas il
faut pas mourir guéri donc il faut
reprendre notre aval et c'est vrai il
faut reprendre on respecte pas toutes
les consignes de 2,2 dirige de
protection aux sanitaires etc etc et ne
vont pas mourir guéri mais surtout il
faut éviter la casse sociale parce que
c'est vrai finement aura des
conséquences dramatiques
on le compare aisément à la guéguerre la
reprise du travail sans visage donc pas
mal d'endroits comme dirait une
possibilité de travail partiel
cela permet plusieurs choses d'abord de
décongestionner les transports
deuxièmement ça permet effectivement en
certains salariés qui ne se supportent
plus haut qui ne supporte pas le travail
le télétravail de reprendre le travail
et également je le disais au début de
mon propos il faut éviter la casse
sociale parce que il ya trois tiers il
ya un premier tiers comme entreprises
qui ont un beau bilan est honteux des
capacités financières importantes qui
vont passer cette crise il ya le
deuxième guerre celui des entreprises
fragiles mais qui ont des fonds propres
se lit aides à trésorerie
ces entreprises passeront également et
il y un dernier tiers ou des entreprises
qui sont fragiles qui sont eux qui
subissent la fin le confinement qu'ils
bouffent pas ouvrir ces entreprises
d'art je ne veux pas qu'ils soient les
sacrifiés de la crise il faut les aider
à limiter la casse à s'en prendre aux de
l'entreprise daskal ferme
majoritairement vont représenter ce
qu'on appelle le risque systémique
c'est à dire toutes ces entreprises qui
vont faire faillite ont seulement causé
des dégâts dont des entreprises qui
revient donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
effectivement reprendre le travail
ceux qui peuvent le faire et il faut le
faire dans des conditions bien précises
et les entreprises nous appelle dise
voilà comment on peut faire
non il pourra accès à tous les pays
qu'ovide 19 effectivement l'état ne
considère pas que le port des masques
est un préalable à la reprise c'est
nécessaire mais ce n'est pas un
préalable
il faut en avoir et au medef nous
essayons de donner le maximum
d'informations possible à nos adhérents
pour leur permettre justement de trouver
des possibilités pour commander les
matches parce que nous allons faire la
promotion d'une plateforme qui va
permettre de compter des masques ne
s'offre avait travaillé avec les
services de l'état et avec la région
pour disposer nous medef d'un lot très
importants de masques qu'on pourrait
distribuer aux petites entreprises aux
commerçants ceux effectivement tous
peuvent pas aujourd'hui disposer de ses
bas cela nous souhaitons réellement que
la reprise du travail se fasse parce que
il ne faut pas que la france soit pas
radiés et il faut que l'économie
reprenne
parce que la mort économique va être
terrible après le choc humains et icade
je dirais que il ya beaucoup d c'est
quand même il faut pas qu est un
deuxième choc ni celui d'amour économie
alors bien rond d'accueil en charrette
bezina duclair et jean baptiste du père
bonjour
dans un instant puisqu'on était mais on
était sur le problème de savoir comment
ça va se passer dans les prés de l'ours
berne feuilles êtes directeur du
développement économique de 50 a
justement vous devez avoir ces
questionnements des entreprises
comment faire est ce que vous êtes et ce
que vous même vous pouvez les aider
ne serait-ce que sur les précautions à
prendre évidemment le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est la question du retour progressif a
été soulignée c'est bien les retours on
a de toutes les entreprises c'est à dire
que l on envisage un retour progressif
avec pour bon nombre d'entre elles à la
fois à maintenant télétravail et la mise
en place évidemment de toutes les
mesures et de tous les équipements qui
vont permettre à ceux qui seront
présents de le faire dans les meilleures
conditions
alors il ya ce nombre de questions qui
se posent via une question sur la
responsabilité évidemment que j'ai
entrepris ce qu'avec un sujet que le
medef a beaucoup porté de façon à
permettre que j'avais plus possible
rassurer sur leurs soins sur sa
responsabilité on aura en a lancé une
série de webinars à destination des
entreprises
laurence intervient régulièrement et je
la remercie vivement pour on va apporter
des conseils informer nos chefs
d'entreprise la première question
évidemment qui nous pose c'est quand
même celle des transports parce que ces
éléments fortement orientés à la fois le
volume et les conditions de reprise donc
là c'est le premier point que nous
sommes en train de travailler avec le
ile-de-france mobilité le 2 une
accélération d'août et une passion de
faciliter le retour au travail c'est
aussi la question des tests et c'est un
sujet que jean michel fourgous et
prennent landes 50 ans anisé étudie pour
trouver des solutions très opérationnels
pour nos entreprises et mais où on avait
là pour l'état justement est ce qu'il ya
des réponses concrètes que je ne vais
pas le sujet le sud là où aujourd'hui
nous sommes tous de faisabilité de façon
à travailler en travaillant avec les
laboratoires puisque la question c'est
aussi que ces tests soient évidemment
réalisés par les laboratoires qui ont
toute la capacité à la fois de pratiquer
et d'analyser cette est donc ce travail
est en cours et nous allons interdire
compter sur sur leur intérêt par rapport
à une plate forme donc la question de la
mobilité la question des thaïs la
responsabilité juridique du chef
d'entreprise
et puis voilà beaucoup de l'hostie de
deux propositions de produits et
services de la part de nos entreprises
bon on a de teint de mettre les
entreprises de reprendre de reprendre
rapidement ont été mêlés situation
fragile très fragile que nous comme aux
identités et des accès à dire je les
passais le paris foot gay dans un
instant mais je vais devoir vous libérer
donc je voulais parler avec vous vous
demandez aux faux qu'est ce que vous
espérez de la situation dans les deux de
ce qui va se passer dans les semaines
qui viennent pour les entreprises est ce
que il ya besoin d'encore depuis
d'autres défendent eux n'est pas de plus
des aides de but de facilitation sur le
chômage partiel ou insulte tout ça
marche plutôt bien
et qu'est ce que vous vous espérez pour
les entreprises pour que les entreprises
puissent vivre et revivre et évidemment
facilité le neuf la reprise économique
enfin notre prise à temps et là
plusieurs jours
effectivement on a parlé de la
responsabilité de l'employeur
nous avons nous souhaitons qu'ils aient
un décret est claire m et précis qui a
dit que l'employeur il a une
responsabilité de moyens et ne pas une
obligation de résultat c'est très
important parce que ça veut dire mais
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il faut que
le chef d'entreprise met les moyens en
place pour protéger ses salariés
maintenant peut-être contamination qu'on
puisse en faire de la responsabilité de
cette contamination et surtout si un
décès par la suite au chef d'entreprise
ça ça va faciliter la reprise du travail
ça va permettre sur d'entreprise d'être
un petit peu moins stressés mois dans le
lac
si vous voulez de cette responsabilité
qui pourrait rehausser
alors comme je pense que docteur lambert
on peut effectivement le dire la la le
virus est extrêmement contagieux et même
quand on prend effectivement à des
mesures barrières etc
on n'est pas absolument certain qu'on
sera pas atteint ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est
effectivement les aides aux entreprises
les uns dans deux coentreprises doivent
être facilitée parce que ça n'est pas
facile pour toutes les entreprises
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
quand il faut pas oublier que
l'entreprise qui va demander de l'aide
elle va s'endetter et donc ça va
dégrader et je pense que il touché et
plus experts que moi là dessus ça va
effectivement pénalisé
j'allais dire le bilan ou le haut de
bilan d'une entreprise parce que il faut
faire face à la période de confinement
mer des emprunts de trésorerie mais
derrière tout l'investissement reparte
si on veut que l'investissement reparte
il faut pas que ces emprunts qui sont
faits aujourd'hui pour répondre à une
problématique de trésorerie pour
répondre à une problématique j'allais
dire de blocage du chiffre d'affaires et
je dirais venir un petit peu empêché des
entreprises d'emprunter demain pour
investir et pour se développer
ce qu'on demande effectivement à l'état
c'est aussi cette problématique de
records des charges et le taxent propos
de parts de charge et de taxes ça n'est
qu'un report il va falloir les payer
demain monsieur est donc voilà donc ça
si vous voulez ce sont des choses qui
vont permettre la reprise et qui vont
courir mettre le déconfinement dans les
entreprises qui va se faire un petit peu
plus plus plus aisément
merci une cote sg vous d'hiver parce que
je crois que vous avez beaucoup parce
que je voulais juste
je remercie juste sa carrière six
enfants et courage évidemment et pour
votre entreprise et pour les chefs
d'entreprise que vous aider pour
présenter oui je voulais rassurer
zachary les les entrepreneurs n'ont pas
d'obligation de résultat en matière de
santé sécurité
c'est un revirement de jurisprudence de
2015 et une ordonnance qui a été pendu
sur le sujet justement du pôle it 19 au
mois d'avril a rappelé que les
entreprises n'avaient pas d'obligation
de résultat mais une obligation sur
l'appel de moyens renforcés c'est à dire
qu'il faut vraiment y mettre en place
toutes les mesures et des leurs qu'ils
ont mis en place toutes les mesures ci
bat quelqu'un attrape le politicien tu
as peur qu'on sait pas d'ailleurs à s'y
met en place toutes les mesures
il n'y aura pas de retient de rapale la
responsabilité excellent précision merci
merci beaucoup
laterrière vite alors qu'on sait bien la
latte la vie des entreprises
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas frappé quand
même par au fond on a l'impression la
fragilité comme tissu industriel du
tissu des entreprises
oui ça c'est cette sorte de 2,2 de
marronniers de l'économie les
entreprises françaises sont sous
capitalisées
c'est c'est pas trop notamment en ce qui
concerne en ce qui concerne les les pme
mais moi je vais continuer à être un peu
iconoclaste dans cette affaire suis
d'accord ce qui a été dit mais mais là
il est urgent de changer de discours
parce que l'on se rend pas compte mais
on a inventé viser les français et on a
des collaborateurs aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont complètement tétanisés
alors le problématique des fonds propres
il existe mais si on bat des
collaborateurs qui sont liquides à
l'idée de venir travailler
qu'est ce qu'on va faire il faut il faut
que le politique je suis d'accord avec
je crois c'est jean charles lajoie ni
donc le politique fasse de la politique
et que l'on qu'on cesse de nous passer
des professeurs à longueur d'antenne qui
nous expliquent qu'ils
si l'autre cela demain moi je fume je
suis content parce qu'apparemment la
ridicule problème c'est que là il faut
il faut qu'on reparte dans un discours
qui soit un peu plus économique que
vraiment on donne aux envie aux gens de
retourner travailler parce que on est
dans un truc totalement surréaliste bien
sûr que je suis d'accord exa carrés sur
l'idée qu'il faut alléger les charges
faire des reports aider les entreprises
mais dont on parle de 2 milliards qui
circulent mais comment on va les
rembourser ces milliards l'état l'état
l'état ne peut rien moi je il est urgent
d'avoir un discours pro actif sur le
redémarrage de l'économie de dire et de
redire qu'au fond il n'ya même pas 1%
décès dans cette histoire absolument
quelques bon bah voilà
moi j'ai lu un témoignage d'un médecin
de campagne qui disait hier et bien et
laissez nous travailler
gg j'ai fait un petit sondage auprès de
deux personnes entre 85 et 95 ans j'ai
la chance d'en avoir un dans mon
entourage et même applause là que
personne ne se souvient de la grippe de
hong kong
plus personne donc bon allons-y coiffe
hop où on est on est on est dans une
société qui me fait peur tellement elle
a peur d'elle-même quoi et donc on peut
si on reste dans cet état d'esprit
oui bien sûr il faut faire tous les
gestes barrières nécessaires il faut
prendre toutes les précautions utiles et
nécessaires mais il faut bien partir
il faut repartir bonjour juste moi sur 7
sur cette peur collective et tape sur
cette démission du pouvoir politique
face aux médecins face au pouvoir
scientifique excuse a l'impression qu'on
est maintenant plus gouverné par des
médecins que par les politiques comme le
disait oui il faisait et jean charles
lajoie n'y ait que des voix ronde et on
est gouverné par le principe de
précaution et là ça devient précaution
seulement trop d'émotions une sorte de
démission du pouvoir politique face au
besoin de scientifiques pour justement
il est peut-être qu'on est un peu
gouverner par la peur et les principes
de précaution
non je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
véritablement de mission je crois qu'il
ya surtout un constat qui est celui
d'une communauté scientifique qui est
unanime pour dire que soient certaines
choses qu'on a connu d'elle soit on
certains membres de la communauté
synthétique avancé des éléments qui sont
fournies par d'autres scientifiques donc
face à ces incertitudes ou certaines
choses qui sont connus mais qui
finalement ne permettent pas de déduire
certaines de ses créations
et bien tout simplement le président de
la république prend ses listes comme il
dit et il n'a d'ailleurs pas d'autre
choix que d'en prendre car il sait pts
pandémie nous met dos au mur comme bien
français de faire des choix entre une
préférence pour plutôt l'économie pour
plutôt la santé donc je crois que là
pour le coup le principe de précaution
est un principe qui ne peut pas être
pris puisque de toute façon il comprend
ddcs constant fille est ce qu'on est
content non plus qui est confiné est ce
qui me correspond quelques le président
a rappelé bic est sans gouvernement
prend sa responsabilité
nous verrons d'art s'il échoue il faut
absolument les consignes il faut des
confiner les on dit on n'imagine pas le
les dégâts psychologiques et sociaux que
ça induit chez les gens deux mois deux
mois de confinement cet appui aux
monstrueux
ensuite il ya quand même toute une
partie de la population qui ne se
confine pas du tout et que à finir par
trouver un peu curieux qu'on puisse
laisser des gens ne pas se confiner se
promener 24 heures sur 24
et puis que d'autres gens seraient
absolument obéissant et c'est donc
maintenant ce confinement
il a été bien ou pas bien les décisions
ont été prises c'est tout à fait normal
qu'ils ont vertement réagi
maintenant je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec qu'il fauchait jeu réagir c'est
cette maladie encore une fois n'est pas
létales pour cent pour cent des gens
bien au contraire celle inverse donc pas
non plus une catastrophe absolue
donc laissons les genres travaillait
arrêt tour de dire aux gens vous allez
risquiez votre vie
on laisse des débats s'installer sur le
retour à l'école par exemple sur le
retour dans les lycées mais c'est
totalement démontée on est en train de
fabriquer des générations antilles en
entière de 2,2 de gens qui vont être
terrorisé paniqué à la moindre idée de
sortir de travailler de faire quelque
chose cet absolu
tragique c'est tragique il faut sortir
de cette seconde de justin tv on donne
tout à fait ce besoin de reprise
économique
et je le partage je suive aussi victime
du style mais il faut aussi prendre
conscience que même d'un point de vue
économique
s'ils ont des confinement qui global
massif qui n'est pas raisonné qui n'est
pas organisée il n'est pas sécurisé on
va s'exposer à un deuxième pic
épidémique utilise que d'être pire que
le premier et à devoir ou confinées
encore plus durement derrière c'est ce
qui est en train de se produire plus ou
moins au japon et on a énormément de
doutes sur l'immunité
face à ce virus donc évidemment que la
situation allait catastrophique mais il
faut aussi faire en sorte qu'elle soit
pas pire encore est cette industrie
textile mais il faut que les médecins et
la société économique
je crois qu'au contraire on essaie tous
de co construire quelque chose qui soit
idéal soit pérenne et choix dans ce
débat de l'opposition entre deux mondes
je crois qu'au contraire le monde
médical est au service de la société et
on essaie de trouver des solutions
par contre ce qui est cruel c'est
qu'effectivement on a un manque de
moyens est sale et a une responsabilité
là dessus aujourd'hui nous vivons une
période de la france est l'un des pays
finalement qu'il est plus des trucs et
on a 25 morts pour 100000 habitants
alors que l'allemagne en a que cinq pour
cent mille habitants
il ya vraiment des questions à se poser
et quand j'entends gharib une prétention
je belgique on a là les cinq ans la
belle sera juste une wii on essaie serre
il ya eu des problèmes au niveau du
maintien des élections au niveau du
maintien du match de foot par exemple on
n'avait été aussi en retard sur les
mesures de confinement et aujourd'hui on
prend de plein fouet des erreurs
peut-être justement dans la gestion du
risque qu'on aurait pu mieux gérer
jean-charles et puis j'ai deux choses
bien évidemment si on laisse tout le
monde confiné tout le monde sera guérie
s'effrite à mon avis une solution qui
n'est pas la bonne alors on peut on peut
prolonger le confinement de six mois il
est évident que là on pourra dire c'est
merveilleux car sachez ce n'est ce n'est
pas le but on voit l'exemple de la suède
où ça se passe très bien et puis
arrêtons de soi qualité sur les chiffres
vous dites qu'on a moins de moins de
morts que qu'en allemagne
ok mais on en a enfin plus de morts
qu'en allemagne mais en belgique ils en
ont deux fois plus que nous alors c'est
cette comptabilité morbide des d'être là
ne veut strictement rien dire
regardons plutôt les autres exemples
tous les pays d confine tous les pays
s'y met avec des puisque vous aimez les
chiffres avec beaucoup plus de morts que
nous des pays d confine déjà à are et
ont un petit peu dire que tout ceci n'a
n'a plus aucun sens parce que
effectivement dans deux mois on reste
confiné on va ouvrir les portes
bien évidemment comme on est confiné on
est pas on n'est pas affectée et donc on
peut toujours craindre une vague mais
alors ce mois là dedans 10 ans n'en sera
toujours là on sera toujours confiné
chez nous bien c'est merveilleux bon bah
oui ok mais il ya plus personne aux
urgences
y'a plus personne personnes attrapent la
maladie mais mais dès que quelqu'un
sortira de chez lui il va l'attraper
donc ce n'est à l'évidence pas la
solution regardons un peu style ce qui
se fait ailleurs
je ne critique pas du tout ce qui a été
fait dès maintenant faut peut-être passé
une étape suivante et que regardons ce
qui se passe dans les pays qui ont clos
justement plus intelligemment
la suède est un exemple absolument ya
deux semaines il ya même la grèce il ya
relativement peu de bande des pics
histoire très bien économiquement mais
pas le vieux mas demain disait on disait
souvent en matière de football vous
savez à la joue au football et à la fin
c'est l'allemagne qui gagne et on a
l'impression que c'est un peu la même
chose pour le virus est moins deux
semaines si on vous entend et
sous-entend une semaine oui c'est bien
justement est ce que parce qu'on l'a vu
beaucoup mis en mise en cause
au fond le sna centralisation le nez
d'une administration tatillonne
est ce que justement c'est parce qu'ils
marchent aussi en allemagne c'est que il
ya une coopération entre l'état fédéral
et les länder et que alors qu'en france
on a l'impression qu'il ya d'un côté un
pouvoir régional qui essaye de faire ce
qu'il veut qu il ya beaucoup d sia tva
pouvoir central qu'il bloque les choses
alors c'est c'est possible que ce soit
quelque chose qui nous coûte même si on
a le contrer
qu'italien aussi qui est un état
régionalisée et qui vit n'a pas du tout
fonctionné dans la gestion de la crise
au mans au départ donc je ne sais pas si
c'est vraiment le modèle de gouvernance
qui est en cause mais c'est vrai qu'en
tout cas il ya des questions qui doivent
se poser on l'avait déjà vu avec
lubrizol en début d'année mais question
la sécurité et de la santé sont des
questions qui aujourd'hui sont encore
très cintrée baiser et je pense pourtant
que il ya une vraie appétence de la part
des citoyens et de la part des
collectivités elles-mêmes pour se saisir
plus de ces questions donc je pense
qu'il ya une articulation qu'on n'a pas
encore trouvé dans cet état d'urgence
sanitaire entre niveau central et niveau
local de là à savoir si c'est ça que
nous coûte notre mauvaise organisation
sur le virus
je n'en suis pas convaincu parce que je
pense que il ya une impréparation qui
est dû à des as des as des choix qui ont
été faits antérieurement on a parlé des
masques plusieurs fois etc
mais mais mais il ya eu une
impréparation véritable de notre de
notre état nous est-ce que c'est dû à la
centralisation et décentralisation je
suis pas sûr que ça soit a vraiment
cette échelle de gouvernance qui soit la
réponse sur justement sur pourquoi
certains pays guérigny cloud qu'est-ce
qui peut intervenir là dessus
dominique allemand où il faut chez non
moi je ne sais pas je ne sais pas dire
si certains font mieux ou moins bien que
nous je pense qu'il faut sortir moi il
n'y a pas d'opposition et je n'ai aucune
opposition avec le monde médical et
scientifique
tél il faut absolument respecter les
gestes barrière c'est clair mais ça
c'est presque du bon sens
ce que je voulais dire tout à l'heure et
c'est surtout pas aller on ouvre les
portes et youpi youplaboum c'est comme
s'il ne s'était rien passé
évidemment que non mais entre cette
aberration d'un côté et l'autre
aberrations comme le disait jean charles
lajoie ni ou à tous finir par mourir des
contreurs parce qu'on est resté trois
ans dans un bocal
il faut trouver un moyen terme
raisonnable et surtout je pense que là
on est dans la philosophie qu'est-ce
qu'on privilégie la santé où l'économie
ni l'un ni l'autre
probablement mais pas que là
santé donc on dirait que là le sentiment
de mort ne doit plus exister dans notre
civilisation c'est pas possible c'est
des cartes qui disait je crois vous
mourrez pas parce que vous êtes malade
vous m'aurez parce que vous êtes vivants
oui c'est ça le problème
donc prenons toutes les précautions et
on en prend beaucoup et je pense
d'ailleurs que le président de la
république l'a compris il essaye de
pousser mais utilisation c'est compliqué
parce que la mort c'est quasiment devenu
anormal c'est pas possible
donc moi je dis prenons toutes les
précautions absolument nécessaire
effectivement il faut que le pouvoir
local et en particulier les communes
disposent de moyens et de tête de
possibilité d'agir plus fortes qu'elles
n'ont aujourd'hui mais réveilleront les
marchés avec des conditions
particulières ré où vont les entreprises
et on va on va s'en sortir on va s'en
sortir mais attention attention
attention c'est pas possible moi je joue
et je m'appelle parce qu'on n'est pas de
panique
michael et me florence michael est ce
que je trouve si vous voulez je suis
bien évidemment d'accord pour qu'on
rouvre dans de bonnes conditions
mais justement heureusement ces
conditions on n'arrive même pas fournir
des masques pour les soignants nous dont
10 avec une telle romas comprendre que
nous héritons situations en france ça
qui actuellement est catastrophique
la pinte du stock de masques on a aussi
voudrait semblablement un problème en
france avec certaines mesures d'hygiène
on va dire qu'il devrait être naturel
qui ne sont pas et c'est peut-être des
raisons pour lesquelles une femme très
attends je m'amusais à regarder tout à
l'heure un français sur quatre ne se
lave pas les mains après être passé au
brett hawke ya aussi un changement
peut-être de mentalité à à opérer et
voilà et je pense qu'effectivement on a
une situation qui est très compliqué
actuellement
quant à nenê quand même beaucoup de
morts par rapport à la population et
avec à une pénurie terrible de masse
c'est particulier et sans compter que
plus on découvre sur le virus et on
al'impression loison danser c'est dire
que vous pouvez voter quand même
beaucoup plus rapide que rapport au
virus du sida
dire qu'on down on a des connaissances
sur ces comics disney beaucoup plus fort
est en même temps pour des concours de
choses plutôt bien se passer attitude ce
qui est grand l'aîné des évidemment la
gouvernance très difficile durant ce
mercato
pardon oui ce que je voulais revenir sur
votre question qui était pourquoi
l'allemagne fait mieux que la france
alors il ya aussi un point chez nous qui
a été sur le démarrage de la maladie si
vous avez 200 salles de 1500 personnes
qui sont venues prier dans le grand est
avec la mal de personnes qui était déjà
atteinte et ensuite dans leur dos qu'ils
ont contaminé là bas et ensuite ils sont
repartis tous chez eux ils ont contaminé
chez eux donc les allemands n'ont pas eu
ce loupé matic de 2500 personnes dont
une grande partie infectée qui on a fait
partir aussi le co vide dans l'eure dans
leur pays donc je pense que ça aussi
c'est un élément qui est pas neutre
entre alpha et justement sur ce que
disait mais quelle nombreux c'est à dire
le manquant même de masquer l'absence
pour l'instant de test est-ce que les
retours des entreprises qu'on nous avait
des chevaux et je voudrais les gens qui
travaillent dans les entreprises
quels sont les retours vous avez là
dessus qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui vous
demandaient ce qu'ils nous demandent 9
est-ce que vous pouvez fournir est ce
que la communauté vous fournir des
choses la demande d'aller del sur sur
sur les masques de façon très
prioritaire aujourd'hui une collectivité
on peut jouer un rôle davantage mais
comme en dessous ni tout à l'heure les
basques doivent être changé plusieurs
fois par jour les fissures à re
démarrage finalement qui recherchent
pérenne
la solution de chaque entreprise est il
fourni par l'état où la vie des
collectivités ni vraiment pas la
question aujourd'hui c'est surtout de
pouvoir faciliter le travail
d'acquisition de ces de ces masques
coiffe les centrales d'achat sont
effectivement des outils qui sont leurs
rêves aujourd'hui il ya deux centrales
d'achat qui sont particulièrement
actives sur sur l'île de france la
chambre de commerce a lancé une centrale
d'achat qui est dédié pour des tpe/pme
donc ça veut dire que certain nombre de
fournisseurs ont été référencées et ça
facilite aussi le fait de évidemment
commandes et de sa sont plus ma cible de
bénéficier de tarifs plus attractifs
la région a aussi ouvert sa centrale
d'achat aux entreprises donc les
orientations qu'on m'a donnée c'est
plutôt effectivement de faciliter le
travail et la recherche de fournisseurs
à la fois fiables sur des produits qu'on
a pu valider et c'est une belle et sur
laquelle on peut intervenir et nous
aussi donc voilà le medef fait aussi en
réflexion sur ce sujet donc nous notre
avis mais plutôt un appui à la
constitution de ces que ces centrales
d'achat et de cette plateforme qui n'a
qu'un centre est jules à la solution la
plus pertinente sur la question n'était
de toute façon on a vu c'est une des
conditions du déploiement
donc il faut que ces pestes va
évidemment soit vous savez qu'il ya deux
types de tests donc quand la question
vaut mais c'est la validation des tests
de sérologie et puis après il faut que
les collectivités et là on va jouer
évidemment nos voix contre rôle
s'investissent pour faciliter les en
place c'est les plateformes de test
c'est là dessus qu'on travaille sur 50
ans dit mais c'est d'offrir la capacité
de logistique mais je crois que c'est le
cas dans tous les territoires de sang
gagner pour pouvoir accueillir très
rapidement dès lors que ces tests seront
validées donc d'accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions la réalisation de
l'epc test avec avec des plateformes qui
sont pensés en amour et qui évidemment
prennent en compte tous les enjeux déjà
cette épargne a laissé notre tuer c'est
effectivement mettre en place des
conditions pour que les entreprises
puissent redémarrer rapidement
donc oui elles sont en demande lui on
voit plein d'entreprises
le distributeur de produits dont le
renvoie plutôt à être vigilants et
s'adresser aux plateformes de laquelle
il a eu le travail en a moins de
certification des alors là il nous reste
à peine même pas trois minutes donc
comme conclu justement ce que le disais
quand même c'est que il ya cette
incertitude scientifique qu'est ce que
ça peut être gouverné dans ces
conditions est-ce que c'est prendre des
risques et jusqu'à quel point on peut
prendre des risques peut-être jean
baptiste duclair et une semaine jean
baptiste mettre des micros si vous
parlez oui je crois que de toute façon
nous n'avons pas le choix de prendre des
risques puisque la situation l'impôt ma
cadette disait justement que les grands
hommes un homme d'état serait fonction
de sa capacité à profiter des vents de
la fortune et donc justement
d'adaptation en fonction des situations
je crois que là l'occasion est donnée au
gouvernement qui en place de faire ses
preuves
il est vrai que pour l'instant il est
très contesté mais je ne doute pas qu'à
l'avenir un bilan sera fait et peut-être
que nous découvrirons que au regard des
moyens dont nous disposions au regard
des connaissances qui étaient les nôtres
aujourd'hui et bien les meilleures
décisions étaient prises pour l'heure
nous devrons pas dans le domaine très
rapidement sur est ce que au fond peut
gouverner en dix ans allez-y peut-être
que vous allez mourir mais c'est tout
l'économie doit voir partir on vous
entend pas on ne les entend pas c'est
pas l'économie qui doit repartir c'est
la vie c'est la vie qui doit repartir
c'est sera décisif qu arrêter de l'onu
disent que les gens se remettent à vivre
et une mise mais vous comprenez droit
des régions à des morts mais une
politique de bains où il faut chez
nickel lumbroso florence mercadé il
faudra pour moi l'état les balles à
prendre des risques avec notre santé il
peut prendre des risques financiers
peuvent prendre des risques strates
j qui peut pas jouer avec notre santé
pour moi il est la mission de l'état
c'est de gérer le risque au mieux et il
sait justement cet équilibre entre la
santé l'économie et une gestion qui se
fait au plus près avec des moyens qui
sont malheureusement très limite
actuellement en france il faut j'ai je
suis évidemment d'accord avec cela mais
je pense que le politique qu'il soit
national mais aussi territoriale et doit
avoir un discours positif et est moins
inquiétant qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui on
peut très bien être précautionneux
attentif et être positif sur l'avenir
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
particulièrement sur les chaînes de
média d'infos quotidienne se le dise
quoi est totalement négatif
d'où les reportages qui laisse encore
dans la famille machin le truc dans la
famille bidule et on parle pas de tous
ceux qui vont bien et de ce qu'ils ont
envie de sortir de ce qu'ils ont envie
de bosser
donc je suis d'accord avec michael
lumbroso mais changeons si ce n'est de
paradigme au moins de disco c'est tout
cas d'échec et oui je suis tout à fait
d'accord à ce qu avec ce que vient dire
yves là je crois qu'on va se remettre à
vie il faut vivre un peu autrement en se
préservant et en préservant les autres
dans le président dit voilà on va se
déconfit nez mais il faut que chacun
soit responsable
les autres et je pense qu'il ya une
grosse formation à faire sur la passe
comptent se protéger auprès de jugement
c'est parce qu'il y en a qui vont le
faire naturellement qui en a beaucoup
qui l'on peut dire ça me casse les pieds
parce que c'est gênant parce que si
parce que ça et qui vous prend des
risques pour eux mais surtout qu'ils
vont faire prendre pour qu'ils vont
aussi être dangereux pour les autres
donc alors sortons sortons mais à
protéger ou toujours dit oui sortons et
puis vérifions que que les gens sont
suffisamment intelligents pour faire
attention ça c'est une est une évidence
et puis voilà
arrêtons de stigmatiser et d'avoir cette
sorte de pensée unique qui est de de
dénoncer les gens qui sortent de
critiquer toutes les décisions d'être
d'être effectivement l'elysée y toucher
d'un pessimisme déprimant et retournent
au travail et enfin moi j'ai pas arrêté
on n'a pas arrêté il ya heureusement il
ya une france qui bosse il ya une france
qui s'est un peu arrêté et je pense que
là ça serait bien que toute la france se
remettre à bosser vraiment et et comme
le disent beaucoup d'un politique
il faudra probablement bosser plus parce
que ça fait deux mois que la france est
arrêté pour qu'elle redémarre et ben il
va falloir bosser sûrement plus qu'avant
et hier lundi avec bonne humeur est en
train elle est incertaine et sous-entend
nom des salaires intéressants pourtant
décrire l offre cette fois merci merci à
tous d'avoir participé à cette édition
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
parce que évidemment l'actualité est
très songeons très beau vanter et
peut-être que les vérités d'aujourd'hui
le serons moi demain en tout cas ça sera
intéressant dans des bacs merci à tous
et à très vite pour un nouveau parfum
merci on va voir
[Musique]